hi everyone and welcome to and their
eighth another HD tutorial and in this
video I'll be showing you how to upgrade
your current version of the skype
chatting client and messaging and
calling and video chat client I'm going
to teach you how to upgrade to skype 4.0
the newest version which happens to
still be in beta for windows but I'm
going to show you how to upgrade this
anyway right now what I'm going to do is
actually exit out of the actual skype
client while we're reinstalling it then
we're going to open up a web browser
this case it's going to be Safari and in
any popular search engine just type in
skype and the first link that comes up
will be calm um if you have already
watched my video on how to use or how to
download the original version of skype
let's do so so you can have it and this
upgrade will be even easier for you so
just click on skype calm and the first
link that you'll get is the one that's
telling you you should download skype so
let's wait for this real quick i'm also
from kind of hogging bandwidth because
i'm downloading a video file here but
right here it says download skype
four-point-oh windows and if you didn't
already know over here it says skype is
also available for windows in a business
version they act the regular windows
version which is in beta mac OS 10 linux
windows mobile Wi-Fi phones which is
really need voice over IP phones and
also other cordless phones a specific
note a phone so basically what's new
about skype is that basically the
quality and instantaneous pneus of it
it's almost like being there i would
recommend skype to anyone who hasn't
used it already and who wants to have
free pc to pc calling or PA chatting or
just just chatting regular like a i am
for anyone else and you can click on
this link right here just learn how boys
over IP actually works so i'm going to
click the download now button even
though i already have a version of type
it's going to say view would you like to
open skype full setup EXE I definitely
do now this is a 22 megabyte file in
case you were wondering and it's going
to render in about 15 seconds so let's
just wait for it while I exit out my
other
internet browser all right when this is
done you're going to get a little dialog
box saying do you want to run it and
i'll say yes and this will pop up a
little little command would you actually
like to do it from UIC which is actually
invisible to catch studio but in
Camtasia you would actually have been
able to see that so yeah it says hello
and thank you for downloading skype and
I'm obviously going to select English
and I do accept the end-user license
agreement and the prior statement I'm
going to hit the install button so here
it's in school installing skype which
one may take a few minutes which is why
I'm going to pause this video and come
back to you guys right when it stopped
alright it looks like the window just
disappeared actually that it's finished
dialog box the whole installation
process is over and I'm signing right
back in also if you ever feel like
skyping me I love taking your calls
answering whenever and actually they are
the interface is going to be a little
bit different this is taken to get set
up to see what's new in skype to find
your friends and to check how to sound
works now if you already had friends and
contacts in skype you're going to have
them already so close welcome screen
start using skype here is here is
exactly the new interface over on the
left you can see there's a few different
little icons here seeing how you can
actually there's 11 million people
online just a little different fonts and
you can still change the same thing go
ahead and watch my video on customizing
site extras for it that will actually
blend in as basically add on just like
you would have in on firefox and also
you can send SMS and choose and you
still have all your old context that's
really good thing and also you can see
on your video let's go ahead and make a
video call to a friend it's the same
interfaces I really light and i am glad
i upgraded to skype four point oh also
um when you upgrade to skype you will
get a three-way calling which is really
neat so i am going to Sam just away
right now that's basically and I hope
you enjoyed this video tutorial and if
you have any other requests just
subscribe and save a message and I'll do
my best so thanks for watching guys and
enjoy skype for peace